insanların 3 yaşında başıma gelen
talihsiz bir olayla başlamak istiyorum
Öncelikle
insanlarımızın genellikle insanların
yapmış olduğu
sorumsuzlukların ve
ihmalsizliklerin Aslında bir nevi bir
olayını yaşamış bulunmakta Ama
genellikle insanlar ihmal ve
sorumsuzlukların bedelini Kader diyerek
Kader olarak adlandıran Aslında başının
bu sorumsuzluğu kader diyerek
geçiştirdiği bir dönem hepimizin
hayatında vardır ve ben de böyle bir
dönemden geçtim 3 yaşında ayağımı bir
makineye kaptırmam sonucunda
sol diz altı ampute bir birey oldu
Ve tabii ki de hayat
doktorlarının işte ayağa dikilseydi
kangura alma riski vardı ve
tamamen ayağını üst bölgeden kesme
şansımız vesaire olabilir gibi
yorumlarla ayağımı tamamen kaybetmiş
durumda oldum ve 4 yaşında Tabii ki de
acılı bir aileye veya yaşanmışlıklara
bazı öyküler belli bir noktadan sonra
tabii ki de ee zor veya kolay bir süreç
artık kolay da diyemeyeceğimiz zor bir
süreç aslında bizi bekliyordu böyle bu
süreçte
elinden geldiği kadar ailem annem babam
ve beni tamamıyla o yaştaki bir çocuğu
ne kadar çok seveni varsa birçok İnsanın
sevdiği ve birçok insanın Aslında
ailesinden olabileceğin bir
hikaye dönüşmeye başlayacaktı 4 yaşında
bir protezle tanıştıktan sonra
hayatımın ilk adımlarını atacağım ilk
adımları Aslında anlamı atmıştım benim
için hayatımdaki en değerli varlık
anneme koşarak adımımı attığımda
dünyanın Evet o an dünyanın en mutlu
çocuğu olabilir
ve
O andan sonra hayatın artık İyi veya
kötü tatlı veya acı neler çıkarabileceği
nelerin üstesinden gelip
gelemeyeceğimizin Aslında Hayata bir
sıfır geriden başlamanın aslında bir
hikayesi olacaktı benimkisi
4 yaşında protezle tanıştım ve birçok
arkadaşımın çocukluk arkadaşlarımız
birçok arkadaşımın hayatından oynadığı
oyunlardan işte basketbol futbol işte
sokak oyunları Misket oyunları gibi
birçok oyunda aralarından ayırmamaları
bisiklete binemezsin dediklerinde
bisikleti öğretmeleri bisiklete biniyor
olmak
Aslında benim çocukluğumun ne kadar
güzel geçebileceğini bir göstergesi de
hayatım boyunca ta ki 10 yaşıma kadar
küçük bir kasaba küçük bir köyde dünyaya
gelmiş bir çocuk binlerce İşte o 50 tane
60 haneli herkesin evinden birisi olmak
Herkesin çocuğu olmak herkesin oğlu
olmak Aslında
hayatında Evet ben böyleyim Ama hiçbir
insan beni çocuğundan veya normal
gündelik hayatında Engelli olarak
görmeyip ayırmadıkları bir dönemdi
Aslında ta ki Eskişehir'e Ee
Eskişehir'in ilçesinden Eskişehir'e
gelmem de
hayatta insanların acımasızlıkları
insanların
dışlanmaları
beden eğitimi öğretmenimden tutun işte
okuldaki bütün
arkadaşlarımın işte sen engellisin sen
yapamazsın sen bir şeyi başaramazsın
dedikleri bir döneme girdim Aslında ve
ta ki bu dönem benim bir hayallerim
vardı benim
yaşamam gereken
yaşayabilip ve bunu en büyük üst
noktalara taşıyabilmem gereken bir
hayallerim vardı
hayallerimin bir tanesi babamın çocuk
yaşta bir basketbol topuyla
bizim bir basketbol takımımız var bu
takıma Katılmak ister misin
Tabii ki de dedim ki hani Neden olmasın
Ben neden yapamayalım ve bir gün
antrenmana takılma antrenmanına
gittiğimde şöyle bir şeyle karşılaştım
Herkes tamamen spor sandalyelerini
bilmişler ve çapraz gelen tamamen özür
üretim sandalyelerle ayakta yürüyebilen
engellilerin de aslında engelsizler o
insanların da o sandalyede olduğu ve o
sandalyenin üstünde yürüyebildi ve benim
ya beyninden geçen tek cümle oluyor
Ben yürüyebilen birisiyim ve sandalyeden
nasıl uyuyacağım tek cümle buydu
sonra bir takım kaptanı vardı o dönem Ee
Bartu hala arkadaşım dostumdur Buradan
da ona şey olsun dedi ki; şeyin çok iyi
Fiziği çok iyi şeyim var altyapım var
yapabilirsin
cümlesiyle Biraz onun gazıyla basketbol
hayatım başlamış olduk Daha sonrasında
aşın karabi birkaç sene burada yetişip
piştikten sonra ilk transferimi Konya
Büyükşehir Belediye yaptım
sonrasında İstanbul'a transfer yaptık
sonrasında
Denizli'ye transfer yaptım sonrasında
Malatya Büyükşehir'e transfer yaptım
derken genç milliler vesaire vesaire
kocaman bir 13 buçuk yıl kadar bir
kariyer yaptığımı gördüm ta ki 2018
yılına gelene kadar Hayaller bitmedi
şimdi hayallerimiz
bir insanın hayalleri bittiğinde
o insanın bittiği andır benim gözümde
Ben hayatım boyunca hep şunlarla
karşılaştım sokakta yapamazsın
tat verici bir cümle bence
yapamazsın edemezsin birçok Ee Ayağında
protezler
engellisi doktorun bile Ee
boyun büyüdükçe kemik kestirme
ameliyatları olurken bir doktorunun bir
cümlesi vardır Benim 18 19 yaşlarındayım
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam bir cümlesi oldu
ya dedi ki evet Çocukluğumda hayatı
protezle beraber hiçbir zaman
kısıtlanmadı ama belki ileri yaşlarda
sanırım hayatı kısıtlanabilir ve
kısıtlanma noktasına gelebilir şöyle bir
cümle kurdum Doktor hiç unutmuyorum
hocam dedim Öyle bir kariyer yapacağım
ki
bir protezle bir protezin engel olmadığı
Bütün ülke dahil Sende göreceksin tek
söylediğin cümle bu
ve Bu cümlenin ardına Tabii ki yani
biraz üstten 2 ile ya ben onu demek
istemedim
Sen de tabii ki de Hayattasın gibi gibi
bir cümleler vardı muhatap dahil olmalı
sadece göstermem gereken tek bir şey
vardı başarı sonuç Hayat hayal dediğimiz
olay gerçekleşebilecek bir şeydir
İnsanlar hayal kuruyorsa
gerçekleştirebilmesi gerek Ben
gerçekleştirebildiğimi düşünüyorum 2018
yılında
Bir hayalim vardı hayalim Türkiye'de ilk
ampute mankeni hayali Türkiye ilk antika
modeli olmaktı
aynaya baktığımda hep şunu gördüm kendim
hiç yakışıklı bulmuyorum Bu arada ama
Neyim eksik bir cümlesi vardır
Kibirli ve ukala olabilir ama aynaya
baktığımda tek gördüğüm şey şuydu dedim
ki ben podyuma çıkacağım
ve
2018 yılında belki Türkmen çok Kadim
dostumdur
bir gün ona hayalimden bahsettim dedi ki
ya böyle böyle bir hayalim var dedim ben
binlerce
engellinin binlerce engelli engelsiz
binlerce insanın ailesinden olabilmek
binlerce insan hayatına dokunabilmek
Amacım sadece oydum bedenin ki Ben ne
yaparsam bunu başarırım ve benim böyle
bir hayalim ve böyle bir yeni bir
başlangıcı ihtiyacım var Çünkü hayatımda
ne yaparsam yapayım Her zaman
hep yeni başlangıçlıklar yeni sayfalar
bir şeye adım atıyorsam sonunun
tamamıyla gelmesini isteyen birisi ve
bunun da yapmam gerekiyordu Hakan Akkaya
ile tanıştım o dediğin dostum ona bir
vesile oldu Hakan Akkaya'nın tek bir
cümlesi var gördüğünde hiç unutmuyor
dedi ki ya daha konuşma bile olmadı dedi
ki
boyun Pusu şeyin çok iyi
dedi ki benim defilemde yer alabilir
misin Evet
bacağımı söylememiştim bile yani ne
kadar bir kötü bir cümle Aslında
bacağımı söylememiştim Ya bu ülkede
maalesef biz bunların tereddütlerini
yaşıyoruz ve bunu kırmam gerekiyordu
yani düne kadar gazete manşetlerinde
şunlar yazıyordu özürlüler şunları
başardı özürlüler diye bir şey yok
engelsiz bireyler Bence daha düzgün bir
tabir olacaktı
ve Daha sonrasında uzatmayın
ve ee 2018 yılında hatırla Eylül ayı ile
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
Hakan'a belli etti filmi yaptım ve şöyle
bir anım var hiç unutmuyorum önce
pantolon kapalı bir kıyafetle çıkıp
ayağımı gizlemem gerekiyordu galiba ve
ben şöyle bir teklifte bulundum
dedim ki; ee
farkındalık olmayacaksa benim engelliler
olunmayacaksa Ben
pantolonumun sol fıçısını bizden
itibaren kesmek istiyorum
kestim
ve defineye çıktığımda ayaklarımı o
kadar titredi hayallerin gerçek olduğu
ve o gerçekleştirmiş olduğun şeyi sana
neleri getireceği hangi kapıları açacağı
Aslında yeni bir başlangıcı ve sayfaları
tamamıyla yazabileceği
kaderini şekillendirdiği Aslında o bir
adım bir eşik eşya atlamanın adımlarıyla
da orada podyumda 46 saniye
sonra
büyük bir alkış büyük bir kıyamet herkes
hayatta Baya büyük bir farkındalık oldu
aslında istediğim kişileri istediğim
noktalarda anlaşabildiğimi ve o kadar
insanın aslında evet Eymen hayal etti ve
gerçekleştirmen gereken şeyler vardı ve
Bence bu seni bayağı birçok insanın
ailesinden biri yapabileceği ve
herkesi bir ışık olabileceğinin adımları
o şekilde attım Öyle oldu
2022 yılına kadar sayısız defile sayısız
katalog çekimi sayısız reklam filmi
sayısız birçok proje yaptım şimdi
basketbolun yanı sıra
ve
hayatımda bir dönüm noktası daha
istiyorum
Her şey okey
oyunculuk eğitimi almak istedim ve bir
gün çıktığın bir YouTube kanalında
sosyal medyada yayınlanan bir program
atlamış olarak daha iyi oldum ve o
dairede olduğum şeyde çok zor şartlar
altında ve Zor ikna edilerek o programa
katıldım
Ben farkındalık yaratmıyorum ben
Sizin yapacağınız kesip biçip
yapacağınız yerlerde duygusal ve drama
istemiyorum söylediğim tek cümle buydu
ve bunun sözünü alarak o programa
katıldım O programa katıldıktan sonra
aşağı yukarı bütün defile ve bütün
kariyerimin üzerine harika Bu projede
benim için ve o programa katıldığında
aşağı yukarı bir 30-40 dakikalık şeyde
ve orada o kadar güzel şeyler anlatmışız
ki orada o kadar şeyleri geçirebilmişiz
ki kameranın karşısında o program
yayınlandıktan sonra sosyal medyadan ve
ee basına aldığım cevaplar şuydu
engel tanımayan adam Evet yani
[Müzik]
kiminin ailesinden kimin eşi kiminin
sevgilisi kiminin çocuğu kiminin
hayatında Beni tanımayan birini Benim
buradaki bir kelimemle bir röportajımla
bir cümlemle hayatının değiştiği
binlerce mesajlar aldım ve bunları
aldığımda dedim ki Eymen Evet abi 29
yaşına gireceksin 2 ay sonra da 28
yaşındasın
ve kazandığı şeyler yaptığı şeyler
yapamazsın
hayatta duramazsın bir mesleğin olmazın
karşılığı
engellisini nasıl yapacaksınız karşılığı
her şeyi gerçekleşmişti Aslında
sonra yılmadım yine bir Hayatında yeni
bir başlangıç daha yaptım
fitnese eğitmeni oldum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
daha daha çok farkındalık daha çok
insana ulaşmak gerekiyordu kesmedi bütün
kariyerler Basketbolu bıraktığım
modelliğe bıraktım mankenle bıraktım
Çünkü biz hayaldi ve gerçekleşti artık
gitmenin uzatmanın hiçbir manası bir
sayfa kapanması gerekiyorsa her kapanış
bir başlangıcın hikayesidir Aslında spor
kariyeri sporu hiçbir zaman bırakamadım
hayatımı hutbeydi Basketbolu bırakıp
modelli hayatında Evet kameraları
seviyorum yürümeyi seviyorum o işi
seviyorum o işi aşığım ama eee
spora daha aşık oluyor ya hani sporun
benim için bir sevgi oldu aşk oldu
sporun hayatında her zaman meslek yaşam
kalite İnsanların hayatına dokunduğu
alan ilk dokunduğum yer orası Çünkü ve
Ee sonra
bir savaş dedim ee spor yapmaya başladım
tekrar spor hayatım başladı Sonra
alanında
spor hayatım başladı gibi spor hayatının
başlarken şöyle bir olay oldu
gidiyorum spor salonunda başlattığım
mantıklı dönemi şöyle bir cümlesi oldu
yapar mısın
Evet yani
belgeleri tamamlayıp antrenörlük
yapabilir misin Hızır değilim çünkü
soğuydu hazır değilim ve hazır olduğumu
düşündüm de bir iki yıl
kendim yaptıktan sonra 2 yıl sonra 20
yaşında fitnesene
aşağı yukarı 8 yıldır yapıyorum galiba
yetmedi orduda insanların aynaya
baktığında huzurla yakalayacağı aynaya
baktıklarında
binlerce her yere para botoksu detoksu
güzellik merkezleri vesaire birçok yere
para harcıyorlar mesela ama o kadar yere
para harcayacağını hocam
sen bize sana para harcarsak bizi belli
bir noktaya taşıyabilir misin acaba
bilmiyorum taşıyabilir miyim birçok
insanı taşıdım bu zamana kadar ee sadece
bir Ruhen yaptıklarımla birçok insanın
hayatına dokunmadığımız Yetmedi bir de
bedenleri el attık
yeni işimden mutluyum binlerce İnsanın
ruhunu yaptıklarımla değiştirebildiysem
binlerce insanın bedenlerini de
değiştirmekten
bulunur ve mutluluk gurur duydum her
zaman Hayat her zaman devam ediyor her
zaman bu yolda yürüyeceğiz hepimizin
işler çıkışları olabilir taksis de
olabilirdim Ama ne olursa olsun ruhun ve
bedenim ve düşünce yapılmış bir zaman
değişmeyecekti değişmedi de
emin adımlarla birçok şey başarı
bildiğimizi düşünüyorum İnşallah bugün
de başımızı şişirmemişindir
benden bu kadar
[Alkış]
[Müzik]